I'm visiting New York City right now
from LA and I'm staying with a few of my
friends and I decided that what better
to do in New York than eat I'm gonna
make my friends take me to all the best
Instagram a little desserts in New York
City pretend to be excited though sure
this city is just waiting to be devoured
let's go
so Jill where are you taking me first
we're gonna compete oh and what do they
have there cookie dough probably Rosie
are you gonna get some dough it's
delicious how beautiful and delicious
yeah oh good so good we got the dogs
some cookie dough yeah he is also here
okay so it was way too cold dogs are at
home and now we're off to taiyaki NYC an
ice-cream place which is perfect for
this ten degree weather
here's personal this is my best thing
I've ever gotten in my life this is our
new uniform friendly you get to keep it
look at this thing look it's got a
little horn
it's really cute this almost is healthy
really good
it's old and it's kind of like green tea
and like red bean flavored a little bit
oh man
it's not like the right bean filling in
the middle it tastes like magic so that
mat you're dripping everywhere why are
you so bad at eating we're at Gelson
grand and we are about to learn how they
make their Instagram famous cannolis
[Music]
it literally is everywhere it looks like
nachos we can't really describe felt
like a Lucy I think so that I'm
officially declaring that and all these
are back this is definitely definitely
instagram-worthy
is almost over but we have one more stop
we're going to cupcake market in East
Village we're gonna get their famous
face cookies I love cookies nobody loves
cookies with me you love cookies nobody
loves cookies on the best we should be
trolley truck rolling it's so sweet and
sugary but not an overwhelming white
cookie not only super super Instagram
obviously it's a really good cookie
today is the day is over thank you guys
for taking me to all your favorite
dessert places in New York City you're
coming with us
nobody loves cookies more than me you
love cookies nobody loves cookies on the
best